we'll now make a strange and
counterintuitive step we you know that
human ramus ohms are linear but we want
to think about them as circular cyclic
chromosomes why would we do this
why would we distort the biological
reality the only reason is that it will
make our algorithmic problem much
simpler while actually hardly affecting
our biological conclusion remember I
told you that analyzing rearrangements
in linear chromosomes is extremely
difficult even if the deal with a unique
Ramanujan analyzing curry arrangements
in multi chromosomal linear genomes
becomes nearly impossible and
surprisingly enough analyzing clear
range MUNs in multi chromosomal genomes
with this cyclic chromosome will turn
out quite simple we are about to
discover it so now we will look at the
cyclic genomes in this case cyclic
genome genome will be circular
chromosome consisting of two chromosome
and we will arrange blocks in these
chromosomes as directed black edges for
example plus a minus B minus D plus C
will be arranged as four edges of this
corresponding orientation of this edges
along z circle it does the start we will
now add to these black edges undirected
red edges that connect adjustments
internal block so the to chromosomal
genome will be represented as a graph
consisting of two cycles these are
cycles important they have edges of two
colors red and black now what do we do
next
first let's notice that for every genome
there are many different ways to
visualize it for example this is
q arranging natural order long cycle but
we can change arrangements of black
edges of Q and how in this case the
cycle look like
well after plus a we should go to minus
B that's what we do after minus B you
should go to minus D that what we do and
after minus DV should go to plus C and
finally to plus a this is the same
genome and the same graph in fact is the
same cycle just visualized differently
now let's try to figure out how a
reversal looks like in terms of this
graph so the start with genome P plus a
plus B minus C plus D and let's make a
reversal on the genome result in case
plus a minus B minus D and let's see how
this new genome Q will look like in
terms of our graph model
well after Class A we should go to minus
B after minus B we should go to minus D
after minus DV should go to plus C and
finally from player C we should go to
plus a so therefore transformation of
genome P into genome Q corresponds also
to transformations of the graph shown
here and how can we summarize what this
transformation does certainly it removes
this two red edges and it adds two new
red edges so in summary a reversal
essentially now has geometric
interpretation it deletes two red edges
and replaces them by two other red edges
on the same four nodes
now let's now talk about fission
breaking a single chromosome into two in
this case a sin Unicron maximal genome P
is broken into a genome with these two
chromosomes genome q
so how does it look like in terms of our
graph so through from plus save you
should go to minus B and from - baby
should go to plus a so it will look like
this and also from minus C we should go
to plus D and from DV should go to C so
you see that geometrically also a single
cycle is broken into two cycles what
does it mean geometrically again once
again we remove two red edges and add
two new red edges and similarly in the
case of fusion reverse operation we
would also remove two red edges and add
two new to new red edges and therefore
we defines the notion of to break a
rearrangement that replaces two red
edges with these two new red edges on
the same phone-ins
what we have just accomplished the
instead of four different operations
reversals translocations fusions and
visions we have a single operation a to
break I described how to model reversals
fusions and fission's as two breaks
what about translocations the same story
here are two linear amazons that after
translocations transform into a blue
chromosome and a green chromosome shown
here once again we represent them as
black red passes let's circle eyes them
by just gluing Zients using one of the
red edges and after we circle eyes them
let's perform this to break we'll choose
this two edges will remove them and
substituted by
other two red edges and afterwards we
will simply remove the edges that we use
for circulation like here which is
essentially linearization of circle
chromosome so if you look at this and
you see that we essentially mimic
translocations
using our graphs and we will define to
break distance as menu number of two
breaks transforming one genome into
another and to break distance problem
input to genome on the same set of
synteny blocks and output the to break
distance between this genomes it's now
time to solve this problem but before we
do this we need to introduce the key
notion in studies of genome
rearrangements with each is called the
breakpoint graph